in the late 1950s William Phillips
noticed a correlation between
unemployment and inflation and I'd have
a picture of this gentleman right over
here Irving Fisher because he actually
noticed that a relationship a few
decades before but the relationship has
taken on Phillips's name really because
his publication kind of captured
people's imagination and the
relationship is not that surprising it
seems to fall a little bit out of common
sense but we'll talk about examples that
seem to go against this relationship if
I were to plot if I were to plot the
unemployment percentage right over here
unemployment unemployment percentage on
my horizontal axis and I plot inflation
on my vertical axis so let me put
inflation here inflation on my vertical
axis then he noticed and I'm just going
to pick random data points that it but
in one year where there was high
inflation there was low unemployment and
then in another year where there was
high unemployment there was low
inflation and it's not clear which one
is causing which or maybe they both
circle back on each other and then in
other years maybe where you had medium
medium inflation or relatively low you
had relatively low unemployment and so
he looked at a bunch of years and
plotted them on an axis like this so let
me do them all in the same color so you
take a bunch of years and you plot them
here so now you have higher inflation
slightly higher employment unemployment
then that year over there and I could
just keep plotting keep plotting some
points over here you could even have
deflation and what he saw is there's a
correlation here that there's an inverse
relationship that if you were to try to
fit a curve to these points and you
could have more points here and I'm just
picking them as random you could fit a
curve that looks something like this you
could fit a curve that looks something
like this there's generally saying that
when you have high inflation so that's
up here so when you up here you have
high inflation low unemployment high
inflation and low unemployment low
unemployment unemployment which is the
low unemployment part is a good thing
and out here
out here you have low inflation low
inflation and high unemployment high and
Eve if this curve goes below the
horizontal axis you could actually have
deflation high high unemployment and it
makes I think reasonable sense we've
kind of talked about it in common-sense
terms before but you could imagine and
once again it's not clear which one's
causing which but you could imagine in a
world just reasoning through it that if
you have low unemployment or you could
view that as high employment low
unemployment one way to view low
employment is that you have high
utilization of the labor market well now
in this situation workers have more
leverage workers workers have have more
leverage and if workers have more
leverage then employers will what will
have to increase wages to attract and
retain employers so they have more
leverage and they have more options
there are a lot of people looking to
hire them employers so let me think of
it from the employers employers
employers raise wages raised wages to
attract and retain employees attract and
retain employees but of course when you
increase wages you are increasing buying
power generally for workers so this is
this is increasing workers buying power
increasing increasing buying power which
would increase their demand so this is
going to increase their demand for goods
and services and if they're increasing
the demand for goods and services it's
going to increase the utilization of all
of the factors of production of land of
capital of entrepreneurship and of labor
and so that's going to lower
unemployment even more and you could
imagine if you already have low
unemployment or and this is just one of
the factors of production but you think
about all the factors of production
they're probably all highly utilized the
factories are running it close to full
capacity you're the
the labor market is running at full
capacity if you increase buying power
you increase demand in that context so
demand is going up demand is going up
lower unemployment capacity utilization
or I guess you say labor utilization is
going down there's less capacity more
demand this is going to cause prices to
go up so this is going to cause prices
generally prices to go up and then if
prices go up now workers have leverage
and options when the low unemployment
but they also have higher costs so then
we'll also say workers have higher costs
higher cost of living cost of living and
this is a very kind of hand wavy diagram
and it's just to make you think about
the overlong dynamics and so workers
have more options and leverage they also
have a higher cost of living the whole
the whole economy is kind of operating
it close to Full Tilt and so they're
going to demand higher wages even more
and then this thing can keep cycling and
keep cycling now this seems a bit
common-sense but there are exceptions to
these in the 1970s the United States
experienced stagflation and that's kind
of the worst of both worlds that's high
inflation and high unemployment so that
is right over here and things that could
cause it and in particular what people
point to in the 1970s and it's always
important to realize in economics people
don't know for sure what was the exact
cause that therefore seldom is only one
cause but one of the things that's often
pointed to is that you had a supply
shock you had a supply shock and the
supply shock was in oil it made the cost
of producing everything more expensive
and so that just drove the prices up but
it really didn't allow it really didn't
allow the country as a whole to become
more productive one way to think about
it is it drove the prices up here caused
a higher cost of living right over here
but this part of this cycle that we
would normally associate with low
unemployment and low and high inflation
was not occurring so this part this part
right over here this part right over
here was not occurring and because those
higher prices were essentially going out
of the country you could you get a
she imagined that they were squeezing
out people's ability to pay for other
things so this the higher cost of the
higher cost of living or the higher
prices for oil you could draw a line
from either one and I know it's getting
messy now you could imagine that it
inhibited demand it inhibited demand for
domestic production so I'll draw a
negative feedback right over there so it
squeezed out people's desire to buy
things from this because I had to pay so
much for oil and there's other
explanations for it when people saw the
low unemployment the government wanted
to print even more money to fuel things
but it did not get this kind of virtual
cycle happening there are some arguments
that there were structural reasons why
the government why the economy couldn't
adapt properly so that employees or
workers and resources couldn't be
allocated efficiently but the whole
point of bringing up the 1970s is to
show you that this isn't a law and it's
not clear what's causing what that there
is there was a situation in the 1970s
where you had stagflation and the
opposite of that was what we really saw
in the late 90s where you had relatively
low inflation and you had relatively low
unemployment so this is a very good
situation that we had in the late 90s
and the argument that many people make
why we were able to do that why this
cycle didn't keep going on and on why
the prices didn't go up is that you had
this other trend of huge technological
improvement you had computers and
telecommunications had this on the
internet 100 is in this kind of super
productivity curve so even though you
had the cycle you had an increased
buying power demand was going up the
productivity of the country was
increasing so much that it did not lead
to inflation and so that's what threw us
there in the late 90s so in general it's
a neat thing to think about it's it's
it's at least to some degree it seems
like common sense but like in all things
in economics it's always a little bit
more nuanced and complicated than just
some little you know some correlation
that that you might observe this could
be generally true but there's always
going to be exceptions to it